[Music]
you've had so much success comedy
television movies you've done it all I
don't think a lot of people know I know
you're hardcore fans do but a lot of
people don't know that you started out
as a singer in a band is that correct
well Wow firewood one yeah yeah you were
lead singer and a ciona dancing wasn't
that not the band yeah showing a dancing
Shana dancing well you've definitely got
a picture or a clip or something ever
knew no wait don't that's all the time
we have but you brought it up so if
you'd like we could you clearly want us
to show a picture this is it completely
this is young Ricky
good weapon good work good work well
wait are you just as Princess Leia I
don't know but you think I'm embarrassed
about how I used to look no that makes
me feel bad about how I look now
really yes Bishop this is the
embarrassing me although you do go out
of your way
now that especially now that Twitter is
is a reality you go out of your way to
tweet embarrassing photos of yourself
photos where you have distorted your
face like it's my hobby yeah yeah I'm
trying to make it my job but there's not
a lot of money in it so I still have to
keep the writing up the idea is to look
as awful as you can you're not allowed
to cheat you know no wigs prosthetics no
props just your your own biology and
that you can do some pretty good [ __ ]
it I found it in the bath if you take
your iphone to the bath which I do right
the water distorts it a little bit and
you can get some crazy stuff so I've
been I've been working on that the last
few months so you you
no one's more dedicated to their craft
you lie on the bat and you distort your
face we actually have I saw this one
this was I don't this was today that's
like a mixture of sort of human and toad
genes yeah it's all really weird
experiment fifties that I didn't think
I'd live right